.
>> IT'S BEING CALLED THE SADDEST
MOMENT IN JEOPARDY HISTORY.
AN EIGHTH GRADER LOSES FINAL
JEOPARDY DURING KIDS WEEK FOR
MISSPELLING A WORD.
>> EMANCIPATION -- WELL, BECAUSE
HE MISSPELLED IT BADLY -- YOU
PUT A "P" IN THERE,
PROCLAMATION.
THAT'S UNFORTUNATE.
THE JUDGES ARE RULING AGAINST
YOU.
>> THOMAS HURLEY III HELD BACK
TEARS.
HE LATER TOLD HIS LOCAL
NEWSPAPER I WAS PRETTY UPSET
THAT I WAS CHEATED OUT OF THE
FINAL JEOPARDY QUESTION.
IT WAS JUST A SPELLING ERROR.
THE INCIDENT BLEW UP WITH SOCIAL
MEDIA WITH MANY COMMENTING ON
JEOPARDY'S FACEBOOK PAGE.
HE GOT THE ANSWER RIGHT.
HE MISSPELLED IT.
BIG DEAL.
HURLEY'S PARENTS CLAIMING THEY
WERE LESS UPSET ABOUT THE LOSS
AND MORE UPSET ABOUT HOW ALEX
TREBEK AND COMPANY HANDLED IT,
TELLING CNN THEY WERE, QUOTE,
SMUG.
>> WELL, BECAUSE HE MISSPELLED
IT BADLY --
>> JEOPARDY'S PRODUCERSES
RELEASED A STATEMENT.
IF JEOPARDY WERE TO GIVE CREDIT
FOR AN INCORRECT RESPONSE,
HOWEVER MINOR, THE SHOW WOULD
EFFECT HELY PENALIZE THE OTHER
PLAYERS.
WE MAKE EVERY EFFORT TO BE FAIR
AND CONSISTENT IN THEIR
TREATMENT.
LAST YEAR, A CONTESTANT WAS
PENALIZED FOR MISPRONOUNCING THE
WORD WIMBLEDON.
>> WHAT IS WIMBLEDON.
>> YES.
>> WE HAVE TO TAKE SOME MONEY
AWAY FROM YOU, REED.
I'M INFORMED THAT YOU VERY
CLEARLY SAID WIMBLETON, NOT
WIMBLEDON.
>> BUT NO ONE HAS LOST AS BADLY
OR BOLDLY AS CLIFF CLAVER ON AN
EPISODE OF "CHEERS."
BUT THIS IS REAL LIFE FOR HURLEY
AND HIS FAMILY WHO ARE STILL
SMARTING FROM THE LOSS.
>> THIS IS THE THING THAT GETS
ME.
EVEN IF THOMAS HURLEY, THE KID,
SPELLED THE ANSWER CORRECTLY, HE
WOULD NOT HAVE WON.
THE BOY WHO DID WIN, 12-YEAR-OLD
SKIEL LER HORNBUCK SET